france is the first guy to put his money
where his mouth is go nah i'm seeing how
much i could potentially make i'm out
man
and you gotta love that you gotta
support him
now it's gonna be terrible if he were to
lose a cyril gone on sat on january 22nd
all this goes out the window well that's
what i'm kind of rooting for francis
because if francis is the first guy to
do this
because you think about it there hasn't
been anybody like a super powerful name
recognition especially a guy in francis
who's in his prime and heavyweight to go
um
i'm going to win this championship fight
i'm going to go test free free agency
because everybody wants to do it
conor would make more which is insane to
say but connor make more money doing
this nate diaz would make more money
there's only a handful and the ideas
make more money doing this
[ __ ] uh sugar shawn would definitely
make more money doing this so ufc for
the first time
has a competitor where guys if they're
superstars it only works for superstars
where superstars can make more money not
fighting the ufc it's
this has never happened before ever
where superstars can go well jake paul
is doing that i can do that
it's very interesting and if you're a
fan
and i hate that because it can come at
the cost of cyril gone losing the fight
but if you're a fan of fighters and you
want fighters get paid and you want
fighters to
not [ __ ] have to have youtube
channels and hold mitts when they're
[ __ ] 40 you want guys like francis to
win
and set the path for other fighters at
his level to be able to leave the ufc
and make [ __ ] you money because they're
not making [ __ ] you money in the ufc
there's only one guy who makes [ __ ] you
money his name's conor mcgregor that's
it outside that nobody is riding off to
the sunset nobody francis has the the
ability now to knock out sirigon become
heavyweight champ and make real real
[ __ ] you money so
you kind of gotta root for francis here
hey and i lo it's nothing against sarah
gone but for the love of the game we
want francis to win for those reasons
because if he wins man you're getting
tyson fury you're getting wilder you're
getting anthony joshua next